let's think about what fraction of this
grid is actually shaded in pink so the
first thing we want to think about is
how many equal sections do we have here
well this is a one two three four five
by one two three grid so there's 15
sections here you could also count it 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15. so
there are 15 equal sections here there
are 15 equal sections here and how many
of those equal sections are actually
shaded in this kind of pinkish color we
have one two three four five six so six
fifteenths is shaded in but i wanna
simplify this more i have a feeling that
there's some equivalent fractions that
represent the exact same thing as 6 15.
and to get a sense of that let me redraw
this a little bit where i still shade in
six of these rectangles but i'll shade
them in a little bit in one chunk so let
me
throw in another grid right over here
and let me attempt to shade in
let me attempt to shade in the
rectangles as fast as possible so that
is one
one rectangle i'll even make my i can
make my thing even bigger all right one
rectangle two rectangles
two rectangles three rectangles
three rectangles halfway there
four rectangles
five rectangles
shaded in and now six rectangles
six rectangles shaded in so this this
right over here what i just did this is
still six
rectangles of 15 of the 15 rectangles
are shaded in so this is still 6 15.
these are representing the same thing
but how can i simplify this even more
well when you look at it numerically you
see that both 6 and 15 are divisible by
3. in fact their greatest common factor
is 3. so what happens if we divide the
numerator and the denominator by 3. if
we do the same thing to the numerator
and the denominator we're not going to
be changing the value of the fraction
so let's divide the numerator by three
and divide the denominator by three and
what do we get
we get
two
over five now how does this make sense
how does this make sense in the context
of this diagram right here
well here we start off with six shaded
in you divided by three have two shaded
in so you're essentially saying hey
let's group these into sections of three
so let's say that this is
this right over here is one section of
three
this is one section of three right over
here
so that's one section of three and then
this is another section of three
right over here
and so you have two
you have two sections of three and
actually let me
color it in a little bit better so you
have two sections of three and if you
were to combine them it looks just like
this
it looked just like this notice it's
covering the exact same area as your six
smaller ones did and then how many equal
sections of this size do you have on
this entire thing
well you have five equal sections let me
go to because this is one
section of three
all right over here this is another
and then this is another section this is
another section of three so notice
you're covering the exact same area of
the original thing your charac you're
covering two
out of the five equal sections so two
fifths and six fifteens are equivalent
fractions so if you wanna say what
fraction of this is covered in the
simplest form you would say two-fifths